you know and I and I kind of thought  about this relationship with Susan I  thought oh god this is gonna mean I'm  gonna have to get I'm gonna have to be  good I'm gonna have to be this is gonna  be about my work that's what it's gonna  be to know soon cause - because because  you actually wouldn't have it any other  way that's right that's right she's  tough she was tough she really was said  she said she said a bar she definitely  said it didn't have to do much to set a  bar I mean she she was the bar you know  she you know you she was an  extraordinary woman and you know and and  and if if we miss her right now it's  because we because someone who could  talk about this time she could find a  son we don't I don't hear anyone like  that